[Music]
my name is Ian Howarth I'm an ex cult
member I escaped from a cult in 1978 and
today I'm going to be looking at some
clips from films all about cults psi
mine Development Institute limited I
actually really wanted to quit smoking
because I'm an asthmatic my doctor had
said I should quit and I found there was
a course in Toronto so I went on the
course in September of 1978 and it was
Thursday night Friday night all day
Saturday all day Sunday in a little
motel and we went home each evening
after each session and by the end of the
course I had given them all the money I
had dedicated my life to it and resigned
from my job I left the group in October
of 78 so after just two and a half weeks
involvement I went through 11 months of
withdrawal the symptoms of withdrawal
are today equated quite often with
post-traumatic stress disorder but there
comes a day when the quality of your
life matters more than the time you've
got left to live this is the end for us
don't wait to be struck down like no
take your drink and lay down your life
with your family it's depicting Jim
Jones before he orders people to die in
Jonestown Guyana in November of 1978 and
I saw these bodies on the front page of
Time magazine and elsewhere
and I thought you know I could have been
one of those people I think for someone
viewing it without knowing what's gone
on prior it will be difficult for them
to understand why would you listen to
someone saying these things they're
idiotic yeah because you're using logic
but the people listening to that in
Jonestown Guyana we're no longer able to
use logic they had been programmed to
understand that he had a special
pipeline to God if he wasn't already God
himself
and so when he said drink the liquid
that was laced with poison they did it
interestingly enough
some people did try and run away and
were shot to death and if you've got a
large population of people such as they
had about a thousand people you give an
instruction that they are to die in any
population of cult members some people
are going to be just a little bit closer
to reality than others we had such a
good example of this where some people
thought oh hang on a minute what's going
on and they headed for the jungle and a
lot of them were shot dead but some made
it into the jungle and eventually back
to Georgetown
only a handful what I don't like in this
little clip is that you see very few
people because they were approximately a
thousand people there when all of this
happened he was wearing dark glasses
because critics would say is eyes were
bloodshot and he was covering that up
but what he told everyone else was the
light of God in his eyes we're not
people over unless he wore dark glasses
I'd give that one a good 8 out of 10
this is a good clip in my opinion it's a
form of love bombing not to recruit
someone but to try and keep someone in
the group at a point where their
critical faculties have come back to the
fore so you bomb that person with love
you surround them with a lot of hugs and
kisses it's as phony as a $3 bill it's
conditional of conditional on toeing the
party line everybody in a cult watches
everyone else and if anyone is weakening
or slipping or whatever the terminology
might be then they'll pounce on that
person psychologically and work on them
a lot of cults used to be visually
identifiable because of their clothing
but after the 1970s
most groups were much more difficult to
visually identify very useful clip I'll
give that eight out of ten
I'm not sure upstate I think this is
such a useful clip as far as I'm
concerned when someone becomes a victim
of mind control as pressure put on the
human mind and a change occurs you go
through a change of personality if this
is the real you it's pushed out of
action and a new you is created this is
such a concern for most cults that
they'll have a person shadowing you so
that if you were to make a phone call
home if the group knows about that ahead
of time they'll make sure that there's
somebody with you and making sure that
you see certain things that might even
be scripted so that's that's great I
would give that a good solid 9 again out
of 10 excellent someone visiting we want
you to talk to you just want to be sure
you're on the right track overall I was
very very concerned about and critical
of the film because it depicted a
deprogramming that was so far from
reality it was just nonsense but that
clip is a good one the issue of
deprogramming has always been very
controversial and what we're talking
about when we talk about deprogramming
is a family hiring the services of
somebody who would be involved in shall
we say a form of counseling where the
person needs to be tained and that's it
you've got to really detain the person
and so it's always very controversial
because families would grab the loved
one and the loved one would be taken
away to what they would normally
describe as a safe house and they
deprogrammer would start to talk to this
person and the person wouldn't be
allowed to leave and the average
deprogramming might take two three four
days something like that he's a great
guy says he's real experienced and
religion and stuff just three days just
listen to him yet in those cases where
deep programming's did occur and they
only accounted for a very small minority
of of cases that was indeed exactly the
sort of thing that would happen so I
give that clip a good nine
you're having a good day you know I know
you know have you ever had the feeling
of being connected to someone in a way
that goes beyond understanding I think
this is a great clip I know when I was
in a cult myself and I had to go out and
meet people I was given two instructions
one was go for people you're attracted
to and to stay away from space cadets
the lady that was talking to me to try
and get me to go to that meeting she was
very very complimentary you know you can
tend to read a little bit more into that
than is actually there they'll say
anything to get you to go to that first
meeting very very good that particular
clip
[Music]
there's a look that some people have
called the thousand-mile stare
originally we don't use it very often in
the field now but back in the 1970s
that's what it was called it was usually
associated with someone that had been
put into a deep trance state and was
sort of looking straight through anybody
in front of them because they had been
put into that state of mind by occult
recruiters standing about this far and
locking eyes on them
got to be another nine out of ten for
sure can you answer the next series of
questions in your eyes yes no if it's
trying to show that they can dig out all
kinds of things from your past that can
be used against you then that's good as
well normally when one thinks of occult
environment one thinks of a group of
people and the whole group is usually
working on the individual but in the
group that that's betraying there are
certainly one-on-one sessions that
aren't terribly disome allure to what
we've shown that this is presumably
trying to show the early days of what
led to a situation where people are
holding a couple of tin cans that are
attached to wires and run to a meter
that is supposed to measure one's stress
level and we talk about techniques of
psychological coercion being used
against the individual and the average
normal healthy person is broken down and
completely controlled in a matter of
three or four days that's all it takes
five or six if we look at this clip in
terms of is it possible for a cult to
harm someone who comes in to investigate
no question about it
cults will do terrible things to their
own members as well in terms of beatings
would it be done in front of the others
possibly needn't be it could be done
quietly elsewhere so the rest of the
members aren't aware I remember I gave
evidence in a court case once in Canada
and afterwards the judge said should I
be concerned about this particular cult
that's on trial here is it possible that
the cult leader will order something to
happen to me and I said well your honor
if you say is it possible the answer is
yes if the cult leader has control the
minds of the members and then fill their
heads with something of a pagan related
nature then that would make sense that
the key issue rather than it being pagan
or something else is the mind control
first that's what comes first in every
situation and then you can get the
members to do anything for you
I'll give that 106 you got your law
degree from Harvard was that enough for
you Wayne nope
Steve profess your theology amazing in a
typical cult the leader will be
charismatic and so that's a good
depiction of a charismatic leader there
what I also like is that he's singling
out individual people in the group and
talking about their academic or
professional backgrounds and that is so
typical as
well you find in cults they've recruited
students doctors lawyers businesspeople
you name it their cults recruit people
and a lot of them are professional
people what we saw in that clip was
David Koresh he was being depicted by
the actor they're talking to the members
of the group and they were based in Waco
Texas and they'd managed to amass quite
a lot of weaponry over the years and
they weren't keen on visitors at one
point in time in the 1990s the
authorities laid siege basically to the
place shots were fired from both sides a
lot of officers with the authorities
were were shot and killed others were
injured
a part of the building was seen to be on
fire and I remember doing a commentary
at the time as it was happening for one
of the television stations and only one
guy jumped out of a window and the rest
stayed inside and and died and that is
so typical of what you would do in a
cult because if the leader says stay in
and will die and then go to heaven or
whatever he's saying and that's what you
do yeah as far as far as the setting
goals that seemed to be accurate they
had a building very much like what we
saw in in the clip there he doesn't look
terribly different from the money in
real life David Koresh so yeah seven out
of ten thanks for your wife or your
girlfriend it's for a good cause
we're a Christian group raising money
for a drug rehabilitation center you
lied to that man Patrick I brought in
$20 for father that's why I love this
clip one group calls it heavenly
deception another group calls it
transcendental trickery and the whole
film is based on a true story so what
did they sell at the door is it can be
anything cacti flowers it can be little
painted something
others and one group there's no Sun
paintings just absolutely anything and
that can change for a week week as the
leader would want it ten out of ten yeah
[Music]
some cults do have schools the standard
of education they get is another matter
all-together normally in a cult children
are a problem children are often treated
very very harshly to keep them quiet and
if you keep them away from their parents
then the parents aren't going to be
distracted at all if you're programming
them or doing whatever you doing with
the parents it helps to break down the
bonds as well because the last thing a
cult leader wants is it is for a cult
member having a loving relationship with
someone else and and for that loving
relationship to start to interfere with
the control that he or she the co-leader
has so no no problem he said go to
Terry's own house and kill everybody in
there Charles Manson ran a group called
the family the Manson Family when they
see a tragedy in terms of people being
murdered as was the case with the Manson
Family and they can relate to that as a
problem and rightly I think some people
think oh well that's just an extreme
example of what we're talking about in
the world of cults for me it's hot going
around murdering people usually gets the
police involved and quite rightly so
most cult leaders don't get you to do
that sort of thing they get you to go
and lie to people about fund raising
activities and so you bring in a lot of
money and you bring in a lot of people I
give that something like seven
you
[Music]